the jurogan experience he's he's one of
the few people that have range like john
leguizamo um like they got that range
where they can go like john leguizamo
could do the clown from spawn and then
come and do like a gangster right that's
a good point and then like leguizamo's
done a lot of rolls man yeah and then uh
depp he did like edward scissorhands but
he could do blow right and blows like
one of my favorite movies of all time
right like he can do both like that's
how i look at those guys he's in that
like range
um he's done a lot of weird movies too
like was that dead man movie
movie was like a black and white movie
on a train like the 1800s
greatest who's who's the best black
actor
the best most talented i would say i'm
gonna tell you why you think i'm gonna
say it's jamie foxx
oh jamie foxx is one of the most
talented human beings that's ever lived
bro
he's got
i don't know what it is about him where
he can do so many different things so
well but he he can play musical
instruments he could sing like a
grammy-winning star yeah he can act like
an oscar-winning actor yes he's a
world-class stand-up comic yeah and he
does perfect impersonations they're
perfect the dave chappelle one is
bananas bananas play that because it's
so crazy bro
i've been telling you you can do that
for everybody though i'm like yo y'all
sleeping like he did ray
but then he did uh like what's another
wild one with range um that was the
homeless guy remember the homeless guy
oh the homeless one was a good one was
the musical prodigy yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah no he can do anything he's he's
literally he's yeah he's weirdly
talented yeah like spooky like he could
do so many different things so well
so this is on his page here put give me
some volume on this
stage
jamie foxx will show up with a sheriff
and all the other comedians just stood
there they're waiting on me to die
everything that's incredible and he
really was there he really was there he
really did jump on that dude
jamie foxx was one of the people that
jumped on that dude when the [ __ ] went
down though did he yeah oh wow
yeah look at that picture that's so very
let me see that again
yeah jamie foxx is uh gonna play mike
tyson in a movie i heard that could be a
tv show apparently oh what is it for for
example it hasn't been announced i just
looked this up the other day it's now
down to like an extended series so like
oh three to six seven episodes that's
better that is better yeah because you
don't want to jam the life of mike tyson
into like a two-hour movie i love series
i think that's a much better way for the
film industry right now that's going to
be interesting i bet jamie jamie will
nail it like as far as his mannerisms
and everything
it'll freak you out you'll probably feel
like you're around mike tyson you're
going to forget it's jamie yeah i forgot
it was ray i wonder how big he's going
to get who jamie to play tyson you got
to get big
oh
boca or they can just do cgi
because he's big already like jamie's
built yeah but tyson's a tank of a human
it's like a different kind of build
jamie's built like an athlete mike tyson
is built like mike tyson right you know
it's just
22 inch neck and just [ __ ] jack
are you playing mike tyson in his prime
like bro you gotta be jacked yeah you
know mike tyson was a tank
just a tank it's not like a regular
athlete body